pendant une vingtaine de minutes il va
se passer beaucoup de choses dans cette
émission eric antoine
alice est parti on a un truc de folie à
twitter alors il faudrait que vous
connaissiez
donc à mon compte twitter ou au compte
de tpm paix ou encore de cyril compte de
tp j'envoie à twitter maintenant avec on
le voit la caméra est ce que vous avez
envie j'en vois c'est un tweeter venu du
futur c'est une prédiction chez a mis
d'accord et pmp officiel cyril hanouna
des huit magie observé c'est quoi la
prédiction c'est une prédiction il a
écrit magie observer notre tp mp
intensément exclusivement langoureuse
encore je vais t'expliquer pourquoi
cette prédiction dans quelques instants
j'imagine qu'il va apparaître sur les
écrans que la lampe à savoir on est sur
des huit ans il a résidé mais
moyennement alors on y va un petit peu
une petite photo comme ça on a sur les
écrans alors là j'ai un petit peu
comptabilisé si vous les amis que vous
avez sur twitter les uns les autres
alors bien sûr et nohra deux cent trente
sept mille personnes te suivent tous les
jours fort c'est à dire c'est une ville
entière les gens adorent
isabelle 40 2006 gas est une sous
préfecture
[Applaudissements]
dax en 335 millions 280 milles pour
thierry alors c'est quand même très
agile 72 mille fans de ragga c'est quand
même si camille regarde la tronche
photos de camille il est le mec était
photogénique tous les angles sont bons
c'est un acteur de cinéma c'est
extraordinaire et jean-michel 342000
followers comme il ya des vieux sur
twitter après ta françois françois 442
non mais pas 2000
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas devenu a pris l'eau mais le mec
n'a pas de téléphone et berna alors là
ça 90 100 90 mais pas de 1000 non plus
le mec avec toujours au minitel en tout
cas demandé mon cher s'il de mélanger
ces quatre ya pas de marco dos on sait
pas lesquels et lequel on va utiliser
cette parution ce magazine cet hebdo
extraordinaire et les dangers s'il te
plaît sur la table comme ça voilà donc
on sait par où se cache parfois qu'elle
mélange quelle boîte et quelle dextérité
du doigt la fois comme dit ça alors
c'est pas grave
tiens tu mélanges et sûrs mais en
dessous le journal je veux pas savoir la
corse on s'appelle on va mélanger
jusqu'à quelle heure tu peux mais on
sait maintenant tu peux te voilà donc on
est bien d'accord je ne sais parler où
sont les capots seule chose à dire on va
refaire peut-être on va peut-être vivre
un petit moment d'actualité
ça me rappelle quelque chose faite par
les fans comme ça m'a rendu malade
support
ça fait drôle quand même à la natation
je vais piquer une carte postale comme
ça mais ce qui serait drôle c'est que tu
mets ta main et je la relis ton frère de
temps mais quand on fait des questions
vous avez aujourd'hui parce que je veux
vous expliquer j'ai tourné un truc avec
nagui cet après-midi et nagui pareil et
il lui a remis un mec qui voulait
absolument que je m'offre un gala jours
c'est vrai sinon j'étais cramé magicien
dans l'après midi ils voulaient fois ci
me paraît à la gt avec nagui revient
donc on est d'accord je ne sais pas où
sur un car postal
je pique comme ça d'accord et la
première carte postale sur laquelle va
tomber ça sera donc l'après la
prédiction de ce soir j'espère on veut
entier c'est à dire que là on a trouvé
on a eu plusieurs cartes en east à gracc
on apprendre la première d'accord la
personne choisie ce soir bernard montiel
bernard montiel 190 personnes regardent
maintenant ce tweet venu du futur
ouais alors cette sommité pmp officielle
des huit tout ça ce soir garder ainsi on
prend la phrase qui est ici il ya une
lettre une première et il commence
chaulgnes ans intrigue m ou magie au
observer notre nom le thé de tpm ray le
i2 attention le inde exclusivement et le
l de l'engouement 20e au lt iae
elles m'ont mondiale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]